this week 48 hours is investigating the
murder of a Florida man his name is
Matthew Trussler whose body was
discovered near his swimming pool this
was back in 2019. his fiance Melissa
Turner called 9-1-1 and at first she
said she had no idea what happened but
then investigators found a security
camera above their neighbor's garage and
her story changed Aaron Moriarty spoke
with her for 48 hours
so as I walked over here you've got the
camera located directly above the
residence Ryan Lagasse Hillsborough
County Sheriff's investigator found a
witness above a neighbor's garage door a
security camera that held Clues to what
happened to 25 year old Matthew Trussler
I started hearing voices and then I hear
what sounds like screaming yelling
too much
just hours earlier Matthew's fiancee
Melissa Turner says she called 9-1-1
after discovering his body he had been
stabbed it's cold she's gone initially
Melissa told detectives that the couple
had been drinking the night before but
that she could remember few details was
there anything physical
violent he was never violent you know
that was amazing with me but when
detectives confronted her with that
audio recording
okay together
Melissa's story began to change he does
get his knives out sometimes he wasn't
him
escalated from there Melissa was
arrested and charged with second-degree
murder with a weapon did you want
Matthew to die that night
oh no
Melissa told 48 hours that she stabbed
Matthew in self-defense that after she
had taken a knife away from him he
grabbed her by the neck
I thought this was it
I thought he was gonna kill me and then
I stabbed him lightly in the back just
to get him off of me investigators also
retrieved security video from inside the
couple's home and prosecutor Catherine
fan says those clips show that Melissa
was the only aggressor that night he's
calmly walking and you can see she's
hunched over she's yelling she is angry
and upset I didn't do what they're
saying I did if I'm going to prison then
I'm going down biting
I'm going down telling my side of the
story
security cameras are everywhere you can
see Aaron Moriarty's report Melissa
Turner's closing act on 48 hours that's
tomorrow night at 10 9 Central right
here on CBS and on our streaming service
that's Paramount Plus